hello America hope you're having a great
Christmas these are my Christmas flowers
you're not real
folks this last week I debated a very
accomplished very funny left-leaning
comedian named Li camp on the Rick
Peterson show a show on CJ ad a network
based in a little country of the North
called Canada and the only reason I show
you this debate or parts of it actually
you can get the full debate over at the
National Center channel link is right
here and that's like ten minutes so I
can't feature it here but I do this all
the time the reason I'm featuring this
one is because AI could actually get a
digital copy but also it's very
indicative of the mindset I've run into
when debating the Occupy movements and
comparing it to the Tea Party I've been
doing that a lot lately really since
this movement is started I'm one of the
few people who's managed to make it out
to many cities and experience it all
across the country so um let me show you
a little bit right here I think you
probably get a lot of people at the
Occupy movement who who just are
frustrated and don't really know what to
do but um you know at a certain point
you have to look at the numbers and say
okay
well over 400 crimes committed violence
keeps places being trashed as opposed to
the tea party where people have gathered
peacefully listen people can protest
peacefully and I think we need to
determine the difference between
protesting and and disturbing the peace
let me adjust these numbers which I
don't know where he's getting these
these crime statistics see and that's
what every single liberal has done when
debating this movement whether it was on
Huckabee Fox and Friends a left-leaning
radio show is right-leaning radio shows
or relatively down the middle like this
one here they simply say well I don't
know where you're getting your numbers
from and don't really take the time to
address the actual argument so I've
gotten my numbers from a few sources
let's just start with a few off the top
of my head I would list the hundreds
more but I don't have the harddrive
space if you folks go to big
government.com John Nolte has an
official list with over 400 incidents
involving crime rate
and theft and you'll see he never begun
to address the argument but instead goes
on to take the the route of trying to
appease people emotionally I think that
should be looked at something beautiful
and rather than look at all the crimes
oh look a homeless person did something
uh so these occupiers are horrible
people how about the fact that we aren't
going to kick them out and we're gonna
let them have free food and free
clothing and that kind of thing all
right well I can address that firstly in
Zuccotti Park you turn them away in
places like Denver
they weren't certain whether or not and
I don't know what you got that I don't
know where you got that from well
again quick Google or Bing search will
show up hundreds of results folks I just
wanted to show this to you a because if
you're conservative
you should know the kind of techniques
your opponents will be using when you
debate them and be if you're liberal
hopefully this video will encourage you
to stop sucking and get some new
techniques Happy New Year you filthy
animals